a Colorado man who pleaded guilty to
killing his pregnant wife and two young
daughters is being sentenced later today
Christopher Watts confessed to the
murders this month in a plea deal to
avoid the death penalty
Shannon Celeste and Bella Watts bodies
were found back in August
mark Strassmann is outside the weld
County Courthouse in Greeley Colorado
with more on this story mark good
morning
good morning all along the twists and
turns in this case have been riveting
and later today Christopher Watts will
be sentenced for a killing spree that
seems both senseless and sinister the
Watts family seemed picture-perfect two
adorable little girls
the pride of parents Christopher and
Shannon Watts 15 weeks pregnant and
expecting their first boy the baby on
Facebook Shannon Watts gushed about her
husband he was the one for me but
investigators say Christopher Watts had
a secret an extramarital affair with a
co-worker he now admits killing Shannon
a month after it began along with four
year-old Bella and three year-old
Celeste we believe that we have a
partial motive I'm not sure if it's the
entirety of the motive but I'll be happy
to comment on that
following Watts his lover said last week
he had misled her from day one telling
her his divorce was almost final he's a
liar nicole Kessinger told the Denver
Post he lied about everything I just
want them back when his family first
went missing Watts claimed to have no
idea where they were it's not something
I could ever ever fathom what happened
in my lifetime three days later he
admitted to strangling Shannon but only
after he claimed he saw her in a baby
monitor killing their daughters because
she was distraught he was leaving her
according to court documents Watson's
now confessed to all three murders after
a 30 searched an oil field where he
worked and found the bodies of Shannon
and their daughters Watts faces a
sentence of life behind bars with no
possibility of parole
at his sentencing we're expecting to
hear from both his parents and his
in-laws but bianna it's unclear whether
he will address the court unthinkable
especially when you think about those
beautiful girls that we see those videos
of mark thank you